they've been going around in circles at
Stormont for two and a half years there
hasn't been a power-sharing government
in Madison's lifetime come on but her
dad says there's no point restoring
devolution unless the politicians stop
behaving like children and actually lead
so a leadership that has a vision of a
future that's different and then leading
people into that and I think that's what
we need is to not just react and respond
or put band-aids on systems and
structures that are fundamentally
feeling I think we need leaders with a
vision that actually can lead us
somewhere into a better future
Northern Ireland doesn't have a devolved
government or direct route from
Westminster there's no health minister
or Education Minister to answer
questions mega Bertie primary school is
so strapped for cash parents have
donated toilet room and we are in dire
straits when it comes to finances at
every level but particularly nursery and
primary and the absence of a functioning
executive really means that school
principals like me who are holding the
whole thing together are have nowhere to
turn we've got nobody to ask for help we
just feel like we are crying out into
the darkness
in contrast to storm on the north coast
is a hive of activity they're preparing
for the open at royal Portrush an
example of what can happen when people
come together according to one Olympic
legend we've had so many people coming
to Northern and once they've been they
want to come back and I think that it
does break down barriers you know you
don't ask what religion somebody is or
what their persuasion is if they come to
take part in sport it's all about
friendship and opportunity there are two
ways to look at this if Northern Ireland
can host the open without a functioning
government does it really need one hour
does its ability to stage an event on
this global scale illustrate the
potential in this place if the
politicians could find their game again
they haven't given up on power sharing
well not yet
but the parties have now spent half of
the five year assembly term attempting
to broker a compromise Northern Ireland
is still waiting for that breakthrough
David Blevins Sky News in